if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to 200 off and two
free pillows at
helixsleep.com
pacman
welcome everybody hope everybody had a
good weekend uh much to discuss so let's
uh get right into it
um we have now a
more public
battle essentially between the most
centrist or some would call it right
wing
wing
of the democratic party meaning joe
manchin from west virginia uh and bernie
sanders
more the left wing of the democratic
party and bernie has basically had it up
to here with joe manchin
and wrote an op-ed not just anywhere
mentioning joe manchin but actually
wrote it
in a local paper to joe manchin in west
virginia which we're going to look at
written in the charleston gazette mail
bernie wrote an op-ed
saying let's stand together to protect
working families we're going to look at
the op-ed
and we're going to look at joe manchin's
response mansion very very triggered
that bernie is doing this so let's get
right into it bernie writing
in america today the very rich are
becoming richer while millions of
working families are struggling to put
food on the table or pay their bills we
now have the absurd situation
in which two multi-billionaires own more
wealth than the bottom forty percent of
americans
uh going on to say the three point five
trillion dollar build back better bill
supported by president biden and almost
all dems in congress is an unprecedented
effort to finally address the
long-neglected crises facing working
families and demand that the wealthiest
people and largest corporations in the
country start paying their fair share of
taxes in fact this legislation would be
paid for by ending loopholes and raising
taxes on the one percent and large
profitable
corporations the bill would take on the
breed of greed of the pharmaceutical
industry
last year alone while one out of four
americans could not afford to fill
prescriptions six pharmaceutical
companies made nearly 50 billion in
profits and the 10 highest paid
executives made over 500 million in
compensation bernie extols the virtues
of what's proposed the bill would expand
medicare
the united states and states like west
virginia and vermont in particular are
seeing populations age meaning more
older americans and people with
disabilities needing home health care
the buildback better plan is not only
vitally important for seniors but is
enormously important for working
families and children
as a result of the 300 direct payments
to working class parents which started
with the american rescue plan we've cut
childhood poverty in our country by half
it would be unconscionable to see those
payments end which is what will happen
if we don't pass the bill and bernie
going on explaining all of the great
things
that the bill actually does it makes
investment in housing we would reduce
homelessness
uh and then it would to some degree deal
with climate change it would create jobs
and bernie says this is being opposed by
every republican in congress as well as
drug companies insurance companies the
fossil fuel industry and the
billionaires they want to keep the
status quo
and bernie says it's now time to do this
and then he says there's overwhelming
support for the legislation which there
is and yet writes bernie
the political problem we face is that in
a 50-50 senate
we need every democratic senator to vote
yes
we now only have 48. 48
two democratic senators remain in
opposition
including senator joe manchin a democrat
of west virginia
this is
directly and accurately calling out joe
manchin
and kirsten cinema although this was in
a west virginia paper this is focused on
mansion
for his unwillingness to just do the
right thing for his own constituents
which i will remind you about with some
statistics in a moment
joe manchin is not pleased that bernie
did this joe manchin has responded in
typical joe manchinese
saying this isn't the first time an
out-of-stater
has tried to tell west virginians what's
best for them despite having no
relationship to our state i would argue
by virtue of understanding the dynamics
of vermont
that bernie sanders actually far better
understands the situation for west
virginians than does joe mentioned but
understand that this is not substantive
this is joe manchin saying get off my
lawn bernie get off any lawn in west
virginia
um
mansion rights millions of jobs are open
so which is ignores the fact that wait
hold on what jobs what do they pay what
are the conditions supply chains are
strained and unavoidable inflation taxes
are draining workers hard-earned wages
as the price of gas and groceries goes
up sounds like a republican senator
sanders answer is throw money on an
overheated economy while 52 other
senators have concerns to be clear
congress should proceed with caution on
any additional spending i will not vote
for a reckless expansion of government
programs what do i think this is
fundamentally about
joe manchin
spent months
saying the problem is the price tag is
too big for these infrastructure bills
and then democrats came to the table and
said okay we can lower the price tag we
could we could reduce this and then
we'll fix that problem right joe
and then joe says well no because a lot
of the stuff that's in here aren't
things we should be spending money on
like for example the climate crisis
at this point
is it just about joe manchin's personal
financial interest like is it is it that
simple uh joe manchin
gets five hundred thousand dollars a
year
uh thanks to
records
uh obtained by alex koch for the center
for media and democracy and published by
the guardian mansion makes roughly half
a million a year in dividends
from millions of dollars in coal company
stock that he owns
the stock is held in ener systems that's
a company mansion started in 1988 and
later gave to his son to run
joe manchin received a ton of money from
fossil fuel lobbyist groups and donors
who usually donate to republicans but
seem willing to donate to joe manchin
because of his position on these issues
so
i don't want to be reductionist and say
it's just his pocket
maybe it is
maybe it is and maybe that's why joe
manchin is taking these positions as
i've said before
west virginia is a disaster and needs
help not an attack on the people west
virginia just look at the data is a
disaster terrible unemployment rate
terrible health care west virginia is
ranked 47th out of 50th in the country
in health care that means access quality
and public health
terrible on education west virginia is
ranked 45th out of 50 in terms of
education that includes higher ed and
pre-k through 12. as far as
infrastructure is concerned west
virginia is dead last 50th based on
energy internet access and
transportation west virginia
like few places in this country
desperately needs this bill and they've
got joe manchin now if they had a
republican i i know i know guys if it
was a republican instead of joe manchin
in the senate he's not voting he or she
is not voting for it anyway
um but this is a state that desperately
needs this and now
bernie taking it directly to joe manchin
and joe manchin doesn't like it will it
change what mansion ultimately does i
don't know we'll talk more about that
tomorrow and what's currently on the
table
colin powell former secretary of state
has died of covet complications this
story is creating sort of an
intersection
of historical revisionism when it comes
to colin powell and his role in foreign
policy when he was secretary of state
this is causing anti-vaxxers to come out
of the woodwork and say
powell was vaccinated and he died
meaning the vaccine doesn't work why
bother and get the vaccine and it is
coming at a time where we are really
wondering what is the future of this
pandemic so let's talk a little bit
about um one article on this and then
we're gonna look at some clips cnn
writing colin powell military leader
first black u.s secretary of state
dies after complications from covid19
his family announced this on facebook he
was 84.
general colin powell former u.s
secretary of state and chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff passed away this
morning due to complications from
covid19 the family wrote on facebook
noting he was fully vaccinated we have
lost a remarkable and loving husband
father and a great american
george w bush said in a statement today
powell was a great public servant who
was such a favorite of presidents that
he earned the presidential medal of
freedom twice
highly respected home and abroad a
family man and a friend
though powell never mounted a white
house bid he was sworn in as bush's
secretary of state in 2001 he became the
highest ranking black public official to
date in the country standing fourth in
the presidential line of succession
um so this is
uh
it would i i won't lie and say this is
not a controversial figure in some sense
uh colin powell still haunted by iraq
and his participation in making that
bogus false case with nonsense
intelligence for going into iraq in 2003
that's probably the worst of colin
powell's legacy the good is that colin
powell did not get pulled in by the
trump cult and even prior to that did
not get pulled in by the right-wing
xenophobia racism cult when it came to
president barack obama so let's look at
what was maybe one of colin powell's
best moments saying hey guys it's not
just about whether barack obama is a
muslim because it's being used as a slur
but it's also if he were then so what
this is maybe powell's best moment i'm
also troubled by not what senator mccain
says but what members of the party say
and it is permitted to be said
such things as well you know that mr
obama is a muslim
well the correct answer is he is not a
muslim he's a christian he's always been
a christian but the really right answer
is what if he is
is there something wrong with being a
muslim in this country the answer is no
that's not america is there something
wrong with some seven-year-old muslim
american kid
believing that he or she could be
president yet i have heard senior
members of my own party
drop this suggestion he's a muslim and
he might be associated with terrorists
this is not the way we should be doing
it so that's maybe colin powell's best
now colin powell's maybe worst
was participating in making that case
for war in iraq based on intelligence
it it seems pretty clear they knew to be
faulty take a listen
my colleagues
every statement i make today is backed
up by sources solid sources these are
not assertions
what we're giving you are facts and
conclusions based on solid intelligence
i will cite some examples and these are
from human sources
orders were issued to iraq security
organizations as well as to sodom
hussein's own office to hide all
correspondence with the organization of
military industrialization this is the
organization and the rest as they say is
history and that was a big factor
in making the case for going into iraq
one of the greatest foreign policy
blunders of recent decades so a complex
figure and of course
we wish his family nothing but the uh
condolences and thoughts that we would
when someone has lost a loved one but a
politically complex guy now in terms of
the vaccination there are people who are
going to say this and they're going to
say see
why get vaccinated colin powell was
fully vaccinated and he still died from
complications from covid remember colin
powell was 84 years old a very very
high-risk group as we know no vaccine is
100
and we have seen a very small number
proportionally but we have seen some
so-called breakthrough deaths what we
should be
saying in reaction to this is wow
it is way more common to die when you're
not vaccinated at any age
i should get vaccinated you look at
public hospitalization data we just got
some recent data from the uk which is
why i mention it
84 of hospitalizations in the uk
were unvaccinated
only half of one percent of covet deaths
in the uk
were fully vaccinated and so while this
does happen statistically and it just so
happens that colin powell is now one of
those in that group
you are overwhelmingly protected from
hospitalization and from death if you
get vaccinated so the message should be
wow
it's newsworthy
because it is so rare statistically that
fully vaccinated people die
this really reinforces the importance of
the vaccines so that is that's the the
mathematically accurate takeaway
um that that we should um get from this
particular situation
send me your thoughts you can find me on
twitter at d pacman tomorrow is the live
viewer town hall
tomorrow tuesday october 19th at 6 pm
eastern we will be doing a wide open
phone lines town hall it will stream
live on the new youtube channel pacman
live
if you look for it on twitch if you look
for it on the main youtube channel you
won't see it it is only on the new
youtube channel pacman live 6 p.m
eastern tomorrow i hope that you will
join me
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night
it's the right firmness i generally just
do way better sleeping these days
because of the mattress helix was
awarded number one best overall mattress
for the last two years by both gq and
wired magazine it is well deserved i can
tell you firsthand every helix mattress
comes with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video our program does depend on
the support of our members viewers
listeners radio audience podcast
listeners whoever you are you can sign
up at
joinpacman.com support the program get
all the great member benefits that come
with it including the daily bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com
this is just absolutely bonkers off the
wall and it's really instructive in
terms of this idea of neutrality versus
objectivity that i've been talking about
for years at this point there is a texas
school official that has been caught on
an audio recording saying that when
teachers teach about the holocaust
there should also be opposing views
what does that mean it's not clear but
it sounds pretty horrible we have the
audio first let me just kind of get you
up to speed with what uh this is about
npr reporting in one texas district
teachers were told to give opposing
views of the holocaust what
a texas school school district is again
the center of controversy after an
administrator reportedly instructed
teachers to provide students with
opposing views of the holocaust
gina petty the executive director of
curriculum and instruction for the
carroll independent school district in
south lake texas
is alleged to have made the comments
during last friday's meeting according
to nbc news which has audio
um let's just go right to the audio why
not uh this is
gina petty seeming to say we need
opposing views about the holocaust
make sure that if
if you have a book on the holocaust that
you have one that has a closing
that has others
gina petty did not respond to messages
requesting comment i met with two
concerned teachers yeah
opposing views guys opposing views about
the holocaust now this is a great
opportunity to again say
neutrality and objectivity are two
different things
there are many
uh individuals who profess neutrality
when neutrality is not nearly is not at
all objective
uh this is an issue on climate this is
an issue in many areas of life and of
discussion when we're being objective
we're honestly seeking the truth
whatever the truth turns out to be
no matter how it might differ from my
preconceived notions or my biases going
in that's objectivity we just want the
truth and we're not going to kneecap
a hamstring or limit our search for the
truth on the basis of our personal
biases
neutrality is about a preconceived
balance
or agnosticism
between different positions
where the truth doesn't actually matter
notice that neutrality has nothing to do
with truth it's just this idea where
you're pre-committing to being
indifferent or neutral
uh or agnostic between different
conclusions or ideas
so when we apply to the holocaust what's
an opposing view to the holocaust like
we should include
not only real history books about the
holocaust but also
like nazi books about how nazis felt
about jews like we shouldn't we should
include
the the explanation of
nazis as to why the jews deserve to die
and students can determine was the
holocaust good or was the holocaust bad
like is that what we're talking about or
we should give a perspective as to why
hitler's goals were noble worthy and
good goals like what what does it
actually mean to have an opposing view
of the holocaust we need the often
misunderstood perspective of the nazis
really needs to be explained to kids and
of course that's part of what we teach
most
serious holocaust studies and you know
what's going on in texas i don't know
but i would hope that it it also is the
case
would include the views of the nazis and
why the nazis believed that the jews had
to die uh as well as those who uh have
medical issues and you know we could go
on and give the whole whole list that's
part of the actual books that should be
used so this is absolutely insane as is
mentioned in the
npr article
gina petty is the name of the woman
allegedly on the recording there
she was asked for comment and so far has
not delivered any comment but the the
right question is the one that you hear
on the audio there
how do you oppose the holocaust
to which petty responded believe me
that's come up now the school district
head has apologized and said
there are not two sides of the holocaust
that's lane ledbetter who put out a
statement saying as the superintendent
of schools i express my sincere apology
regarding the online article and news
story released today
during the conversations with teachers
during last week's meeting
the comment the comments made were in no
way to convey that the holocaust was
anything less than a terrible event in
history additionally we recognize there
are not two sides to the holocaust as we
continue to work through implementation
of hb3979 we also understand this bill
does not require an opposing view on
historical facts as a district we will
work to add clarity to our expectation
for teachers apologize for hurt or
confusion that this has caused now
here's the thing
um
that they may be accurately saying we're
not talking about two sides on the
holocaust
but this house bill 3979 as karen
fitzgerald a spokesperson said for the
district teachers acro across the state
are put in a precarious position by this
bill
our purpose is to support our teachers
in ensuring they will have all of the
professional development resources and
materials needed our district has not
and will not mandate books be removed
nor will we mandate that classroom
libraries be unavailable
but it still does put teachers in a
precarious position where
they have to ultimately say
there is no controversy to teach here
whereas in other areas like on climate
change the entire point of these bills
is to claim there is a controversy and
that it must be that the science of
climate
has to also be opposed by something else
and of course that's very different uh
different situations so while i guess
they're apologizing for saying we need
opposing views on holocaust studies
this is a very problematic bill and
we've continued to see these problematic
bills come out of texas
we'll see ultimately where this lands
tucker carlson has now gone fully
homophobic on pete buddage or boot edge
edge as some like to say
um he a pete buddha judge rather has
taken paternity leave he and his uh
husband
have adopted twins
and tucker carlson
going in on what what is he doing
breastfeeding huh is that why he's
taking time off is he he's taking time
off to learn how to breastfeed
tucker carlson mocks pete buddha judge's
paternity leave as learning how to
breastfeed
fox news host tucker carlson mocked pete
buda judge for taking paternity leave
carlson equated booted judge who is gay
taking paternity leave to learning how
to breastfeed
fox news host such as jessie waters
previously bragged about the network
offering paternity leave let's take a
look at the video clip here is the uh
homophobic attack on pete buddha judge
kind of mixed into some pseudo-political
stuff
but still the white house does not seem
concerned
pete but a judge has been on leave by
the way but a judge his job since august
after adopting a child paternity leave
they call it trying to figure out how to
breastfeed no word on how that went but
now he's back in office as the
transportation secretary and he's deeply
amused he says yeah
um it's funny how the manly the
supposedly manly right wingers who are
alpha
and they support the troops and they
support being tough and america being
tough and being tough at the individual
level
they have as a hero tucker who never
served anywhere
making fun of pete buddha judge who's a
veteran
because he's taking care of his kids and
mocking him in a homophobic way now let
me address one other element of this i
got a few messages from people and saw a
ton of comments online
saying stupid liberals saying this is
homophobic this isn't homophobic at all
it's it might be stupid but it's not
homophobic
now i hesitate to even you know
sometimes when when people ask for
explanations for certain things it's
like if you're asking for an explanation
you're not gonna understand it you're
not gonna see it i don't know i don't
know that i can make you see it but let
me try
homophobia often seeks to feminize men
breastfeeding is something that
biological women do
and pete buddha judge is gay it's a very
very simple
uh feminization
of a gay man that that's all it is and
now that he's a father it's well is he
breastfeeding is that what's going on
it's a very
simple lowbrow bigotry that's all it is
and tucker carlson's audience absolutely
loves it now
buddha judge was asked about this a
couple of times
you know whether
whether pete needs to respond or not
sort of up to pete buda judge but he
said i'm not going to be apologizing to
tucker carlson
says as you might imagine we're bottle
feeding and doing it at all hours of the
day and night
and i'm not going to apologize to tucker
carlson or anyone else for taking care
of my premature newborn infant twins the
work that we are doing is joyful
fulfilling wonderful work it's important
work it's work that every american ought
to be able to do when they welcome a new
child into their family i campaigned on
that and pointing out also that uh
paternity paid paternity and maternity
leave in the united states far more rare
than it is in many other wealthy
countries so
it's uh you know it it's sort of similar
to the vaccine stuff with tucker
my assumption is he's been fully
vaccinated for a long time he was first
in line but he's taking the
preconceived notions and biases of his
audience and the ignorance of his
audience to monetize
opposition to vaccination requirements
and putting out stuff like the vaccines
may have killed tens of thousands of
people etc etc i don't think it's really
what tucker believes but it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter because the
impact on his audience and on the
country is the same whether tucker
really believes it or not
i don't know nor do i care
whether tucker is really homophobic or
really has a problem with paternity
paternity leave he is weaponizing it and
monetizing it because his audience
absolutely loves the thinly veiled
homophobia and that's fundamentally what
this is all about and everybody at fox
news seems to love it in terms of what
it does for their ratings at the same
time fox has paternity leave we know
jesse waters took it and much like fox
behind the scenes has one of the
strictest vaccine mandates of any large
corporation yes uh what happens on-air
and what happens behind the scenes are
two very different things we'll have
more on this on our instagram make sure
you're following us on instagram at
davidpakmanshow and you can follow me on
instagram as well at david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so we're getting closer and closer
really to the start of the 2022 midterms
and one of the signals that will be
important in 2022 about 2024 if we're
continuing to wonder as we are about the
future of trumpism as something that has
the republican party in a vice grips for
lack of a better term
is how people that are aligned with
trump due in 2022 versus people who are
not aligned with trump due in 2022 and
we have to that end a very very
interesting new report from bloomberg
which looked at
fundraising
for various republicans
that have not been in the pro-trump wing
let's take a look at this and see if we
can learn anything from it trump's picks
lag cheney and republican incumbents in
fundraising cheyney of course being
lynn cheney
liz cheney sorry a chaney upton and
herrera butler voted to impeach donald
trump
trump pac hasn't donated to their
opponents
three house republicans targeted by
former president donald trump
raised more money in the third quarter
than his hand-picked candidates to
defeat them according to the fec filings
representatives liz cheney of wyoming
fred upton of michigan and jamie herrera
butler of washington were among 10 house
republicans who infuriated trump
by voting against him during his second
impeachment proceeding so far republican
donors haven't followed him in backing
their challenger so already two
important bits of news here number one
voting to impeach trump in that second
impeachment trial despite what trump and
other trumpists said
doesn't seem to have been a death blow
to those individuals at least so far
they're raising more money
and number two an endorsement from trump
in these particular cases at least
isn't actually helping the opponents to
these individuals raise more money now
we've still got a while right these are
primary races we've still got a while
we'll see what happens
but so far both of the claims you're
going down if you voted to impeach me
doesn't seem like it and number two my
endorsement is gonna rocket people to
the winner's circle not not actually
happening so far let's continue uh trump
has yet to endorse candidates running
against the other six republican
incumbents who voted to impeach him on a
charge of inciting the january 6th
insurrection at the u.s capitol but is
vowed to fight them as worried
republican officials republicans need to
flip only a handful of seats to gain
control of the house in 22 and weakening
incumbents seeking re-election by
funding primary challenges would
complicate that task another republican
who voted for impeachment representative
anthony gonzalez said in september that
he wouldn't seek re-election his trump
endorsed challenger max miller
took in 695 000
including half a million of personal
funds he loaned for his campaign in ohio
16th district miller also got five
thousand dollars from save america
trump's leadership pack now listen to
this this is very interesting
though trump's committees had a hundred
and two million dollars in the bank at
the end of june so far he's done little
to spread the wealth around save america
his leadership pack has channeled five
thousand dollars to some incumbent
republican senators he's endorsed
including john boozman rand paul and tim
scott but some of the house candidates
he's backing have yet to see any
donations through the end of september
that includes harriet hageman a wyoming
attorney who won trump's endorsement to
take on cheney
hagemann raised 301 thousand dollars
and um
cheney has topped 1.5 million each
quarter so it's just it's it's very very
lopsided there
uh herrera butler raised 523 000.
she topped the 450 000 raised by u.s
army vet joe kent that's closer for sure
and upton the um voting to impeach trump
incumbent raised 292k topping 115 000
for steve cara who earned trump's
endorsement in september this this is
interesting in a number of different
ways first of all it would be great to
just see them see themselves uh see them
tear themselves apart and as is pointed
out in the article and as we can sort of
think about
um these could be very weakening
um challenges primary challenges to the
incumbents every indication so far so so
let's think through all of the different
ways in which trump and trumpists have
been wrong
they've been wrong that voting to
impeach trump in 2020 was going to
destroy their chances in 2022. so far
they're doing fine they're ahead they're
raising more money they seem to be doing
fine so they were wrong about that trump
saying you're out doesn't seem to have
the power that trump hoped that it would
have number two
trump hand-picking a replacement
also doesn't seem to be doing that much
for the replacements now arguably
these uh challengers might be doing even
worse had they not been endorsed by
trump we don't know number three even
trump doesn't seem that motivated to
actually help these people at least not
financially as he has barely donated to
any of these hand-picked challengers so
far now maybe it's too early or although
primaries are starting to come up for
some of these folks
maybe it's that
trump doesn't really believe
that they're going to win or it might be
that it this is just part of the grift
trump's raising money supposedly to help
put the right republicans in trump
always says we're going to get the
rhinos out the republicans in name only
are going to go out
uh but
it may be that the real reason for
fundraising is just uh the grift uh
collecting money paying off campaign
debts all of the things that we talked
about trump doing back when he was
raising money to fight election fraud
which by the way we're going to talk
about tomorrow again in some of these
races fundraising might matter less than
in other parts of the country wyoming
for example which such such a small
population
it's less about having the most money to
do advertising i mean the population is
tiny
it's more about news narratives and
personality stuff and maybe endorsements
even would make a difference
uh but in a lot of these races whoever
raises more money ends up winning so
we're gonna follow these but so far
trump doesn't seem to have that golden
touch
and also trump saying get him out of
here they are bad we need to remove them
that also doesn't seem to be damaging a
lot of these people we'll see trump
loves to claim his great record on
endorsements
it's actually not so good actually not
so good speaking of trump and trouble
uh the debt trump is scheduled to be
deposed today
the back story on this is that
throughout his presidency all sorts of
um
complaints were made legal complaints
were made against trump many of them for
sexual assault allegations
but the whole point of trump's uh being
president was
among other things
to say oh no no no uh i'm too busy being
president to actually be deposed and the
records need to be kept secret executive
privilege all these different things
this may very quickly be changing donald
trump faces a pile of civil lawsuits as
depositions begin listen to this
trump is defending himself in at least
10 civil suits alleging fraud and
defamation to incitement of violence
former president trump has been ordered
to answer questions under oath in a
lawsuit today
and his attorneys could set a date for a
deposition in another case as well
the lawsuits involving allegations that
his security guards roughed up
protesters outside trump tower in new
york and allegations of defamation by
former apprentice contestant summer
zervos respectively are just two cases
in the mass of civil litigation trump
faces post-presidency
at least 10 civil cases are pending
against trump whose ability to delay
them has been curtailed since he left
office in january
trump has argued in some of the cases
that as a sitting president he was
immune from civil lawsuits his office
didn't respond to a request for comment
on the cases here's a rundown of the
major civil suit where the major civil
suits stand so you've got summer zervos
that's a name we've talked about before
she's been pushing for this for years
and hopefully now it's actually going to
happen zervos was a contestant on season
five of the apprentice says trump
smeared her by calling her a liar during
his campaign in 2016 after she accused
him of having subjected her to unwanted
kissing and groping when she was seeking
career advice in 2007. an attorney for
trump declined to comment trump's
attorneys have said that his statements
were true and they plan to file a
countersuit
protesters at trump tower also monday
attorneys for protesters who allege
trump's bodyguards assaulted them during
a demonstration in 2015 were set to
question trump trump said in an
affidavit in 2016. he doesn't know
anything about it he wasn't directly
involved in hiring security his
attorneys tried to spare him from
testifying for years including when he
was president but the judge now said his
testimony was indispensable
the videotape deposition was being
conducted inside trump tower where six
protesters were demonstrating in
september of 2015 and they would be used
as testimony when the case goes to trial
you've also then got e gene carroll
suing trump for defamation
that may require trump to be deposed and
give testimony that was transferred to
federal court last year
after the justice department sought to
intervene saying no no no trump's immune
because the statements are part of his
official
responsibilities there's going to be
arguments heard in december there could
be deposition
dates set there
business investors i mean this is this
could be a decade for donald trump uh
trump his children eric don jr and
ivanka and his company are also being
sued in the same courthouse by a group
of people who say the family conned them
into making bad investments
in businesses the trumps were promoting
that's another one that could lead to
depositions
mary trump trump's niece
alleges the family defrauded her out of
millions of dollars from her
grandfather's estate
and allegedly involving donald trump so
that one's going on and then january 6th
trump has been hit with at least four
lawsuits by democratic lawmakers and
capital police officers over the january
sixth riots um trump attorneys maintain
he's immune he was president at the time
the speech that allegedly incited the
riot was protected by the first
amendment we want cases dismissed and
depositions have not yet been scheduled
there's also some voting rights related
claims which could lead to depositions
at some point in time
this is a crazy amount of stuff now even
if trump successfully manages to beat
off having to be deposed in the vast
majority of these
this is an unconscionable amount of
legal bills now these are really legal
bills which donald trump should have to
pay personally
you know this is a topic where we've
seen matt gates use campaign funds to
cover legal expenses early on now in the
possible upcoming charges against him
uh would there really be consequences to
trump if he uses that grifted money
supposedly uh raised to fight election
fraud to pay for legal expenses i don't
know i i know i know you're not allowed
to do it and it's against federal
election law
but
there have not exactly been
repercussions to many members of
congress and various politicians for
doing that using donated funds for
personal legal expenses so i don't
really know it it wouldn't shock me that
trump tries to do it and it wouldn't
shock me if trump gets away with it
quite frankly so we're going to continue
monitoring that and in the midst of all
this donald trump is now asking you to
donate 45 to him to fight election fraud
which if you fall for it at this point i
mean
you you're really disconnected from
reality but we'll talk about that a
little bit tomorrow we'll take a quick
break after the break we're going to
talk about ted cruz's latest uh
statements about the australian coveted
guidelines which by and large have
worked very well we're going to talk
about the resurrection
not not the wrong term right the
resurrection of the war on christmas
and we've got much more upcoming after
this short break
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show all right
let's look at the latest just completely
bone-headed attempt by republican
senator ted cruz to espouse his ideology
of open everything never close anything
asking people to think about someone
else in their community around this
planet is a form of liberal nonsense and
blah blah blah blah blah and as a result
ted cruz has ended up getting called out
very brutally
by michael gunner who's the chief
minister for the northern territory of
australia so
the context of all of this are protests
in australia by anti-masters and
anti-guidelines people
in the context of an australia that has
really taken the pandemic very seriously
and so
let's first start with uh ted cruz's
tweet which was in response to a video
from michael gunner from a press
conference which we will look at okay so
ted cruz tweets quote i love the aussies
their history of rugged independence is
legendary i've always said australia is
the texas of the pacific oh god
the covet tyranny
of their current government is
disgraceful and sad
individual liberty matters i stand
with the people
of australia so the clip being referred
to from the day before
um is a clip related to
guidelines being put in place
potentially fines for violating mandates
etc
this is michael gunner the um as i
mentioned the chief minister for the
northern territory let's take a listen
this is what triggered
ted cruz ask yourself these three
questions
in my work do i come into contact with
vulnerable people
is my workplace at a higher risk of
infection
do i work on infrastructure or logistics
that are critical to the territory right
if your answer is maybe
or i don't know you need to get the job
critically the direction also applies to
industries who directly face customers
and circumstances where the worker may
not know the vulnerability of the person
they are interacting with right so it is
simple
if your job includes interacting with
members of the public then you need to
get the jab if you work in hospitality
you need to get the jab if you work in
retail or in a supermarket you need to
get the jab if you are behind the
counter at the bank if you're a
receptionist or positions like that you
need to get the jam if you are a barber
a hairdresser a beauty therapist you
need to get the jab all these workers
and many many more directly interact
with members of the public that means
you are frontline workers in our economy
that means you must be vaccinated of
course there can be exemptions but these
are extremely narrow and must be backed
up with medical evidence simply not
wanting the vaccine is not a reason
today
we're also announcing the date from
which this mandate comes to effect this
is huge from saturday the 13th of
november if you have not received at
least your first dose of a vaccine you
will not be permitted to attend your
workplace in that role and a failure to
comply with the direction is a 5 000
fine
that means that workers must have
received at least their first dose by
friday the 12th of november
at the latest okay
so that's what triggered
ted cruz to such a degree and uh this
led to
um michael gunner to actually respond to
ted cruz specifically and this guy
really does not mess around the response
from michael gunner
the chief minister for the northern
territories of australia is hey ted cruz
g'day from the northern territory in
australia
here are some facts
nearly 70 000 texans have tragically
died from covid there have been zero
deaths in the territory did you know
that
vaccination is so important here because
we have vulnerable communities and the
oldest continuous living culture on the
planet to protect did you know that
we've done whatever it takes to protect
the territory that's kept us safe and
free we've been in lockdown for just
eight days in 18 months our businesses
and schools are all open
did you know that we don't need your
lectures thanks mate you know nothing
about us and if you stand against the
life-saving vaccine
then you sure as hell don't stand with
australia i love texas go longhorns
but when it comes to covid i'm glad
that we are nothing like
you
um
ted cruz just humiliates himself day
after day after day and one of the
really interesting aspects of this
is that there's the
stereotype of all sorts of different
populations which sometimes republicans
don't like you know all the typical
stuff
uh highly educated is sort of feminine
and
european is sort of feminine and
actually
the trend there seems to be a lot of
stuff is just [ __ ] right according to
according to republicans then they have
stereotypes about the opposite about
those that are rugged and they're sort
of like them they're conservatives and
out on so they talk about hey you know
in switzerland lots of people have guns
they're manly there and they're fine
you go in to talk to you go and talk to
the folks who own the guns in
switzerland and you realize wow they
actually from a legal perspective are
really in line with democrats and they
explain that the role of guns in
switzerland is actually completely
different to that in the united states
they don't understand united states gun
culture but republicans go oh look at
switzerland
similarly
with the australian rugged individualism
and all this stuff
a lot of
the culture in australia is just
different it's not guns in the same way
that there are guns in the united states
it's not
out on the out on the land in the same
way that you know some of these folks in
wyoming and montana uh are wrapping it
up with certain political views that's
not australia it's actually not not it
at all um and ted cruz just embarrassed
and humiliated once again here shouldn't
come as a surprise but maybe he'll go
back to cancun to get away from the
negative repercussions of this one as
well
we sort of haven't talked in a way about
the war on christmas which doesn't exist
for a while
because there was a republican in office
so let me refresh your memory as to how
the war on christmas works it doesn't
actually exist
but now there's a democrat in office so
fox news wants to fully resurrect the
war on christmas when a republican is in
office
as president
the story is democrats want to wage the
war on christmas but thankfully we've
got a republican president so they're
not going to succeed that's the story
when a republican president is in office
when there's a democratic president in
office the story is the full war on
christmas routine the left wants to
cancel christmas they want it to be
illegal to say christmas they want it to
be illegal to be christian they don't
want gifts they don't want anything okay
this year
the war on christmas under a democratic
president is combining with the
possibility of supply chain issues
delaying christmas gifts and so dr fauci
is being taken out of context when he
was asked
last week or the week before about large
christmas gatherings uh it's all being
ramped up and kind of rolled together
now here's a little compilation we will
play uh this is from the recount very
nicely done the supply chain crunch that
threatens to spoil the holiday season
there will be things that people can't
get toys not getting shipped toys like
tonka trucks tonka trucks tonka trucks
yeah uh my little pony characters that's
the type of things that make or break at
christmas
care bears tonka trunks my little honey
we've showed you the kind of trek from
the care bear in a factory in china to
the store in massachusetts well this is
the togetherness care bear and everybody
needs to be together and everybody needs
a hug they're going to be harder to find
if people can't get bacon and people
can't get a tonka toy
yeah that would be that would just be
terrible for joe biden so then the house
republicans tweeted a picture of joe
biden with the caption quote
this is the guys
who is trying to steal christmas
americans are not going to let that
happen
uh and i i know it shouldn't be but it's
still shocking to me that people
continue to fall for this stuff
a headline while peter ducey was
reporting from the white house read
toy association ceo
says it may be too late to save
christmas then at another moment when
peter ducey was reporting it said white
house scrambles as supply crisis
threatens christmas
neil cavuto had an explosive story with
an interview even called christmas tree
sellers hit by supply chain delays and
then on the opinion shows
i know right on the opinion shows laura
ingram had a story called the biden who
stole christmas
sean hannity then ran an almost
identical story called the grinch who
stole christmas but there's a picture of
joe biden in a green suit and tie
yesterday morning there was a segment on
unfiltered with dan bongino that might
be a fox news online show maybe it's an
actual tv show on the weekends i don't
know
the segment was called how the biden
administration is stealing christmas
aaron rupar reported on thursday last
week that fox news mentioned christmas
at least 106 times in the prior 24 hours
this is sort of like the epitome
of the cultural replacing the
substantive for the american right wing
we've talked about it before
this particular story the whole war on
christmas thing goes back to bill
o'reilly and some of those types in the
early 2000s they started this in the way
that it exists now they started it in
the early 2000s saying christmas is
being banned saying merry christmas is
being banned it's an attack on
christianity they're trying to diminish
christianity etc
the re the real genesis of this story is
that there were some companies that
decided to be marginally more inclusive
by saying hey you know what
let's say happy holidays
that that's basically the story and
everybody was fine and life continued
and it was no big deal but that was what
started what is now known as the war on
christmas and now just perfectly supply
chain issues melding with it dr fauci's
comments about christmas which by the
way will follow up on on today's bonus
show he's saying if you're vaccinated
it's probably fine to gather actually
that blended into it and now fox news is
utterly determined
to resurrect this war on christmas
incredible but they're succeeding this
is the type of stuff that does well it
gets ratings it gets people angry the
same way we've got to stop socialism
really what is socialism no it's biden
what
yeah it works it works and they have no
policy and that's why they're doing it
and you're already seeing war on
christmas stuff show up
it's it's it was early october when it
started
it's already there and now it's building
in all the usual online enclaves we have
a voicemail number and that number is
2192 david p
this is a this is a tough voicemail i'm
going to play for you guys today this
voicemail is a combination
of someone who doesn't know what's going
on politically
but also
doesn't understand my show they claim to
understand my show but you're going to
notice in this segment
they say
you're doing white supremacy on your
show david
you're doing white supremacy you're
doing xenophobia you did a segment about
how haitians have aids
seemingly misunderstanding that my
segment was about donald trump's claim
that haitian immigrants are just
bringing aids over that wasn't me saying
it i reported on it and you'll notice
that this is someone who has
this is this is endemic in the united
states many opinions
based on things they misunderstood or
misheard uh so this is in regards to
debate about vaccines um first foremost
like who are you i mean i see a young
guy going with thank you
trying to
make money on the basis of being white
you just seem to go with constant object
on being white or being liked
i'm hispanic i don't even know what he's
talking about but again
you don't have to watch me this is some
people don't seem to understand just
because a show exists doesn't mean you
have to send in every opinion you have
about it or even watch it active opinion
without adding any critical thought
um like i'm trying to figure out if it's
all i see is
all of these
attempts to get the relevancy
43k views 24k views
racist crap like haitian migrants have
aids because obviously you're racist
did you guys hear that
he says that my clip about haitian
haitian
migrants having aids was me doing a
racist segment trump said it
trump said it i'm reporting on it
by the way in terms of average views our
average video now gets seventy five
thousand
often you know two hundred thousand
three hundred thousand the channel's
actually blown up but it doesn't matter
does this person care i mean it's just
it's just so funny because people like
you actually contribute absolutely
nothing to our generation this guy's
contributing a lot though um you know
i don't think you'll do too well in the
long term i love that that's the best i
love it when people who have no idea
what i'm doing say there's no way this
could possibly last it's like well we've
been doing it for 16 years
and last month we were the biggest that
we had ever been this is the circling
the drain meme two of my favorite memes
you're circling the drain every one of
your platforms is dying fact check we're
bigger than ever the other one that i
love
um well actually i wouldn't even i'm not
even gonna gonna uh
the unsubscribed trolls people who say i
i'm i'm now unsubscribing because of
something you said and they were often
never subscribed to begin with or
they're not really unsubscribing okay
that's a departure you're not a
uh you know anyone who really brings any
worth to society
except for trying to get people
excited and
trying to
misinform the general public
so i guess um that's really basically
the argument is that i mean what's the
point of having a discussion with
someone who is
so irrelevant and untalented
what i love about that is
no one's forcing him to have a
discussion with me he didn't even have
to call in from birth that
they need to constantly just try and
enforce some objective opinion
um what does objective opinion even mean
isn't opinion by by its very nature
subjective that doesn't even come from
your own
you know this is a a bunch of
yeah racist kkk stuff on your page yeah
there it is so i'm doing uh um my
channel is a kkk channel so that is just
a really stunning combination of someone
who
doesn't even understand my views
is angry that the show exists
claims its ending soon
doesn't want to engage with it but it's
choosing to engage with it on the basis
of things that they misunderstood or
misread you you really can't fix this
stuff you re i don't know how we deal
with that folks i really don't
we will talk on today's bonus show
high schoolers are training to drive 18
wheelers because of a shortage of truck
drivers high schoolers we will also talk
about dr fauci saying hey you know what
if your family is vaccinated
you can get together for christmas
after being misquoted he's now actually
saying
that's okay to do
and lastly there is a wild situation
developing with chicago police officers
between the mayor and the union over the
vaccine mandate
we are going to talk about what is
happening it's getting very very ugly
with chicago police all of those stories
and more
on today's bonus show
sign up at
joinpackman.com to get instant access
and i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to two hundred
dollars off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com pacman